bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors 81 % des enseignants
qui s'en sentent mal ou très mal
protégés face au virus
c'est un peu un chiffre qui parle de
lui-même oui bonjour
effectivement alors les des images que
vous montrez précédemment sont des
images dans un préau riz dans un collège
où dans un lycée puisque ça concerne les
enfants des adolescents qu'ils portent
le snipper pc un syndicat du premier
degré et là ça concerne principalement
des forcément des enfants qui ont moins
de 11 ans et qui ne sont pas masquer
puisque avant nous on n'entend pas vous
allez de porter de masque et donc
l'explication pourquoi 80% des
enseignants du premier degré sont se
sentent mal protégés ou pas protégés
c'est tout simplement parce que je pense
que les seuls lieux où on peut se
retrouver à une trentaine de personnes
sans que son sans pouvoir porte sans
avoir à porter un masque sans avoir à
respecter la différenciation sociale cds
classes de maternelle et d'élémentaire
en france ce sont les seuls endroits
donc effectivement moi je veux pas
commenter les décisions médicales et je
n'ai pas à commenter les la mise en
place d'un quelconque protocole c'est
juste que on a l'impression d'être dans
une situation de double injonction ou en
fait on nous demande d'être extrêmement
prudent extrêmement vigilants par
rapport à la diffusion de ceux de ce
virus et al'inverse dans les classes le
protocole il est tellement léger qui
n'existent quasiment plus alors le
protocole il a été allégé depuis
quelques semaines ça veut dire qu'ils
étaient plus renforcé les semaines de la
rentrée et moi maintenant
alors le protocole pont pour ce qu'il en
reste effectivement il est alors il est
à peu près le même que celui du dessus
de l'entrée il n'y a pas de modification
c'est juste que on se retrouve dans une
situation de par rapport à la rentrée
qui a évolué dans l'enfance où il ya des
enseignants qui maintenant sont absents
parce qu'ils sont malades parce qu'ils
sont qu'à contacter et du coup on a un
nombre réduit d'enseignants on n'a pas
la possibilité non plus de
de faire en sorte de respecter les
limites du brassage on n'a pas la
possibilité de faire respecter la
dénonciation sociale dans les classes
c'est pas forcément leur revenir à un
protocole de rentrée c'est juste si on
nous demande effectivement d'être
extrêmement vigilant en dehors de la
classe comme on le fait pour l'ensemble
des citoyens et citoyennes en france on
comprend voit que ça s'applique pas dans
l'est dans les cours des enfants dans
les écoles en primaire en élémentaire et
maternelle
alors qu'est ce que vous demandez
concrètement aujourd'hui il ya des
petites choses simples c'est à dire que
effectivement on l'a déjà fourni des
masques qui sont pas adaptés des
machistes textile qui sont là en nombre
insuffisant il n'y a pas de masques ffp2
pour les personnes dites fragiles
on attend toujours les masques
transparent dans les écoles maternelles
est dans les dents les cp on en attend
toujours aussi du gel hydroalcoolique
dans les écoles
c'est pas faux non plus par le ministère
c'est pour lui par certaines mairies par
certains établissements le second degré
mais ces deux c'est toujours pas le cas
et puis surtout dans l'idéal si on veut
vraiment faire respecter la
distanciation sociale c'est à dire il
faut réduire le nombre d'élèves dans les
classes et on peut envisager c'est ce
que c'est ce que proposent les
enseignants qui ont été contactés dans
ce dans le cadre cette enquête qui
s'adresse à 10000 personnes 1 10 mille
pe c'est de réduire à des demies groupe
tout simplement pour pour éviter de
fermer les écoles pour pouvoir
poursuivre notre mission de service
public d'éducation donc ça sous-entend
éventuellement qu'il puisse y avoir un
suivi autres une semaine sur deux
l'histoire que les enfants sont pas
privés pour complètement deux d'école
pendant pendant toute la semaine mais il
faut réduire les groupes pour pouvoir
respecter la distanciation social pour
pour pouvoir permettre de limiter le
brassage c'est nous paraît le plus
évident alors on sait que les décisions
adoptées par le gouvernement sont prises
après conseil avec des professionnels
notamment des professionnels de santé
est-ce que vous enseignant on vous a
sollicité est ce qu'on vous a écouté
écoutez je le redis on n'a pas à
commenter les cylons médical on n'est
pas médecin donc
ça nous concerne pas en revanche sur
l'organisation
on a demandé du pp depuis le puy
l'amiante on a demandé un report de la
rentrée pour les élèves afin qu'on ait
le temps de se préparer à un accueil
correct pour éviter de se retrouver
obligés de fermer cette classe est
certaine c'est que l'on n'a pas été
entendu on n'a pas été entendue non plus
sur sur ce protocole qui finalement ne
respectent pas la distanciation sociale
et donc qui est allé j'ai donc non moi
je considère que bien qu'on a été reçue
par le mystère n'a pas été entendu à
linthal eux merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant et qu'on secrétaire
du syndicat snuipp fsu du nord merci